yeah as Michael said Emma's security and
privacy researcher and I'm here today to
share something cool with you but also
to ask you for help when I want to tell
you about is a problem in that comes up
in the Bitcoin space I'm designing for
usable security and I want to tell you
why it's important I'll tell you why
it's important even if you don't care
about Bitcoin at all why it has
repercussions well outside the Bitcoin
world and I'll tell you why the
community is a little bit stuck right
now in trying to solve this problem
despite a number of creative ideas oops
about that there's my fault is working
now thank you
and this is something that I think would
really benefit from the expertise of
people who have a background in
human-computer interaction it's
something that I'd love to collaborate
on for example but it's something for
you to be aware of as an interesting
research problem if you're thinking
along these lines so what am I talking
about let me start by giving you just a
very quick five minute introduction to
Bitcoin and these you know this very
simplified view of Bitcoin is all that
you'll need for understanding everything
that I'm talking about today
so the first thing to know about Bitcoin
is that bitcoins don't the Bitcoin
system doesn't have accounts like you
have bank accounts instead what you have
is that bitcoins are owned by addresses
and this is a good example of this here
you see the wikileaks donation page and
there's a lot of text on this page but
what I want to draw your attention to is
this string over here and the same
information that represents it as a 2d
barcode over here so what wikileaks is
saying is send us bitcoins and in
particular send bitcoins to this address
right and so why is this address so long
why is it not a human readable or human
memorable thing why does it have to be
gibberish well that's because addresses
are in fact public keys so the first
thing to understand about the bed coin
system is that money is sent to and from
these public keys and all that the
system itself cares about is how to take
care of the transfer of money from one
public key to another the Bitcoin system
has no idea that this string
over here corresponds to WikiLeaks it
doesn't care about that that is
completely external to the system okay
so why does it have to be public keys
well it turns out that there is an
important cryptographic significance to
that having your addresses be public
keys and having money be transferred to
and from public keys allows you to do
something really cool it allows you to
say that in the Bitcoin system transfers
of money are merely assigned
cryptographic statements so what does it
mean to make a transaction in Bitcoin
what does it mean for me to send you
money or what does it mean for me to
send WikiLeaks some money all that it
means is that I would create a statement
a statement is just a string that says
my address I would like to transfer a
coin see which is which has some
identifier or let's say also a string to
some other address B so I create that
string I create that statement and I
sign it with the private key that
corresponds to my public address right
so you might know from cryptography
public private key pairs so I create a
key pair anybody can create a key pair
as many as they want at any time and
your public key becomes the address from
which you send money or to which people
send you money and the corresponding
secret key that you keep secrets
intuitively it sort of allows the sender
to speak for the corresponding address
so what does that mean if somebody sees
a statement out there as string that's
signed by a private key and they can
verify that this private key corresponds
to some address then they know that the
statement was authorized by someone who
has the who controls that particular
address who controls the bitcoins at
those address so this cryptographic
statement itself becomes all that you
need in order to spend bitcoins from
that address right so what happens in
the Bitcoin system is simply these
signed statements floating around and
the only thing that the Bitcoin network
itself cares about is keeping track
keeping a ledger of all of the
statements of the sort that have been
made and putting them in a public ledger
which is called the blockchain which I'm
sure you've heard about right so
conceptually it's an extremely simple
currency system you've got these
cryptographic statements that authorize
transfers of money from one address to
another address and all of these
statements are recorded in the
blockchain that's
so visually it might look something like
this if alice is sending some money she
creates the statement over there on the
left she creates a signature that
happens on her device and she broadcasts
it to the Bitcoin peer-to-peer network
it's a network of thousands of nodes and
notice that she she might be sending her
money to Bob or WikiLeaks or whoever but
that person is not even in the picture
here the recipient it's not as if the
recipients computer is involved in any
way the transfer of money to somebody
merely involves a statement asserting
that transfer being recorded by this
public network in the blockchain so
that's basically all you need to know
about how Bitcoin works but here's the
interesting thing and here's where the
whole security challenge comes from
Alice's device on which you know her
computer or her phone or whatever on
which she creates the signed statement
on which she controls her secret key our
secret Keys corresponding to one or more
addresses that becomes a single point of
failure if she has malware on her device
that Mallory can steal all her keys and
she loses her entire you know Bitcoin
wallet as we call it and that's a
problem this is a problem because this
is very much unlike for example how
banking security works right there are
some key differences in a banking
transaction there is a human in the loop
there is a trend the transaction can be
reversed it's not instantaneous all of
this as opposed to Bitcoin where if
somebody gets ahold of your key or keys
you have permanently and it reversibly
and instantaneously lost your bitcoins
right so software has never before been
the sole line of defense when it comes
to security and perhaps for the first
time it is being put in this position at
least when it comes to financial
security and the result has been I would
say complete disaster look at this
here's a list of all the prime most
prominent acts and thefts and losses in
the Bitcoin ecosystem and if you look on
the right hand column you can see the
u.s. dollars equivalent of the Bitcoin
value that was stolen right I mean
Bitcoin in terms of total monetary value
is only a five billion dollar system so
a large fraction of all the bitcoins
that have ever been in existence have
been stolen
at least once right that is an absurd
statistic and here's another crazy
statistic to go along with that there is
a 2013 study that looked at a number of
Bitcoin exchanges where you can convert
dollars into bitcoins and vice versa
and showed that 45% of them over the
3-year observation period had been
hacked at least once hacked or taken
down or something like that all right so
this is seriously problematic having
your keys that reside on your computer
control your bitcoins is kind of insane
from a financial security point of view
Kaspersky Labs estimates that there are
hundreds of strains of malware which the
first thing they do when they infect
your computer is to look to see if they
have if you have Bitcoin private keys on
them and if so steal them
instantaneously alright so this is a
problem it's it's clearly a security
problem people are having their bitcoins
stolen all the time it's also a
usability problem people simply forget
where they store it they're fed coin
private keys and this sort of story
happens a lot this is one of my
favorites and so this guy had four
million pounds worth of bitcoins that he
had obtained when Bitcoin was a
fledgling currency and so it was not
worth a lot in value but then later it
gradually grew and appreciated in value
and he just forgot that he had his
Bitcoin private keys on this computer
and only on this computer he had not
backed them up anywhere ended up in a
landfill and he even it went to the city
government went to the press to try to
tell his story to see to try to see if
he can convince somebody to try to
search the landfill but of course that
was didn't turn out to be feasible and
he lost them forever right so it's a
huge security and usability problem and
so I actually want to see if you have
any ideas for what one can do to improve
the situation either for security or
usability wise or both I'm going to go
through a bunch of those ideas but I'd
love to hear from you yeah companies
like like coinbase like doing things
like manage your game that's a good
point you can outsource the storage of
your bitcoins to somebody else it
becomes a question then if you you can
really be thought of as using bitcoins
at all in this situation or if that's
just like using PayPal right because one
of the main
reasons you might want to use bitcoins
and so that you have financial privacy
if you're paying someone
nobody's tracking that transaction
there's no link between your real life
identity and your Bitcoin address so
when you is that something most people
will care about that's a good question
but I think to the extent that people
are adopting Bitcoin which is still you
know a fairly niche thing it's because a
lot a big fraction of that small
population is interested in the privacy
properties are you trying to optimize
for that population or are you trying to
optimize for like making Bitcoin go
broader across like people who may not
be another layer sure I think you know
personally I would say he'll take
whatever we can get that's right so
there are three different dimensions
security privacy and usability can you
is it even possible to achieve all three
I think it's potentially possible we
don't have a solution to that yet but if
we can have a really good solution for
just security and usability that would
already be pretty good but even if
you're outsourcing the storage of your
bitcoins it's not an automatic solution
to the security problem because notice
that these are exchanges where people
had outsource these storage of their
bitcoins and even those guys have not
managed to solve the security problem
even though you'd hope that they would
have security professionals there so
it's you know it helps a little bit you
don't need to teach a million people how
to secure their bitcoins only maybe a
hundred exchanges but you still do have
a smaller version of that problem but
yes good point and they have the other
half no one can make a transaction
without both parties being nice we're
going to talk about that too that it is
a solution that people are considering
it's a little bit tricky to make the
crypto work out but we will talk about
that other other suggestions solutions
yeah
we just sort of got behavior privately
encrypted with your with some password
and your backup so that your I mean very
good we'll talk about that too excellent
okay so let me go through a list of
solutions that people have tried to come
up with and before talking about these I
just want to introduce one term which is
the notion of a Bitcoin wallet and so
the idea here is that you're not just
gonna have one Bitcoin private key you
typically want to have numerous
addresses you gain some privacy out of
this you hope that people can't link
these addresses together and so you'll
definitely need software that's going to
manage all of these for you and that's
called a Bitcoin wallet so one cool idea
that people have come up with is to
separate their Bitcoin private keys into
what is called hot storage and cold
storage and this is analogous to the
following if you have a lot of assets in
cash you'd want to keep most of that
cash locked in a safe and only carry a
little bit to spend every day and your
wallet and this is a very similar
concept you can spend your you can
separate your Bitcoin assets into
various private keys and most of your
assets will stay in let's say in a USB
Drive locked in a safe and only a little
bit that you want to spend every day
will be on your computer and accessible
at all times but also more and secure
because it could be hacked over the
network so one key concept here is that
when people separate their assets into
hot and cold storage though what they'll
want to do is they'll want to have an
automated process ideally so that when
you're balanced in your hot storage goes
above some amount say more than 100
bitcoins and you definitely don't want
to be spending that on a daily basis you
automatically transfer the rest of it to
the cold storage on the other hand to
take money out of cold storage you want
to make sure that it's a carefully
controlled and audited process so wait a
minute though how is it possible to
automatically transfer your bitcoins to
a USB device that's locked in a safe how
does that make any sense how could that
be automated what am I talking about
here yes
oh my guess you have a bunch of public
keys for anonymity sir on the USB Drive
uh-huh you don't need the private keys
to transfer - exactly
for to the cold storage you don't need
the private keys of the cold storage
bitcoins are sent to addresses and these
addresses are public keys and recall
from this previous picture that I showed
you that sending bitcoins to some-some
address or some device doesn't involve
the recipient in any way if you want if
you're sending bitcoins to that safe
metaphorically what you're actually
doing is broadcasting that fact to
thousands of computers all over the
world but are ironically not to the
device that's stored in the safe itself
right so that's a cryptographic concept
to keep in mind well yeah this is the
idea behind separating it into hot
storage and cold storage small amount of
money and easily accessible but more
insecure format large amount of money
and less accessible but more secure
format so what's the next idea here
another cool idea is a hardware wallet
here the idea is that if you put your
bitcoins in a hardware device whose
functionality is hard-coded into
hardware or firmware and it doesn't have
a general purpose operating system maybe
it's not so easy for that device to get
hacked right and so you could have an
interface like this if you want to spend
some money the only thing that this
hardware device is programmed to do is
show you an alert with the amount of
money in the address to what you want to
send your bitcoins and then if you
confirm it will actually create the
signature and authorize that transaction
the device doesn't even have any other
functionality so it can't possibly be
used to do anything else such as extract
the private key yeah good point
yes let's come to that so this seems to
you know it seems to solve the problem
of malware but it seems that the problem
of losing the device is still just as
severe as in the earlier case but I'm
claiming that it's not here's what I'm
claiming is possible this is a
particular screenshot of a particular
company I don't know specifically what
their product does but here's what's
something you can generally do with
secure hardware you can program a heart
pre-programmed hard-coded limits into
the device saying that you're only
allowed to spend let's say one Bitcoin
per day maximum unless a specific pin or
password is entered and this limit is
erased wait so you put that device in
that state and let's say the device is
stolen
and let's say you have a hundred
bitcoins on that device and the device
is programmed with the spending limit of
one Bitcoin per day so you might think
that oh this doesn't help you very much
and instead of losing all your bitcoins
at once you have the satisfaction of
gradually seeing your dwindling assets
over a period of a hundred days and
being able to do nothing about it
but I'm claiming that that's not the
case why is that yes revocation key
interesting so there you are
perhaps imagining some way to send a
certificate or revocation certificate to
the device which if it receives that
it'll try to self-destruct it's possible
there's a much much simpler approach
though any ideas
okay right so the fact that your private
keys are on that device doesn't preclude
them from reciting anywhere else so you
could have a backup in cold storage and
so while the thief is limited to
spending one Bitcoin per day and
remember that all of these Bitcoin
transactions are on the public
blockchain so you could easily set up an
alert that scans the blockchain every
day and sends you an email alert if a
transaction has been made from that
address so you notice that and you
immediately take out your key from cold
storage and transfer all of those
bitcoins to a different interest in you
control so this could be a pretty good
solution okay here's another one and
this is I think also one that has
already been suggested which is to
encrypt your wallet file with your with
a password then you pick
so here again we sort of seem to have a
trade off this will protect you against
the stolen device hopefully but it
doesn't protect you against malware at
all why does it not protect you against
malware because you'll have to I think
you were gonna guess so what I was gonna
say anyway which is that you'll probably
have to enter the password on the device
itself so the malware can do some key
logging and steal your wallet file at
that point so but here's the thing
even the protection against a stolen
device ends up being pretty limited in
this scenario it's not super helpful
because we know that people have a
tendency to pick weak passwords which I
think you've may have
nope from Lori craner's work who I here
visited here recently and one of the
things she's most famous for is studying
how people pick passwords and this is
her dress that's that she created that
has the most common passwords on there
so it's it's really a tough ask to ask
people to pick passwords that are strong
enough that they will resist an offline
attack what does that mean what is an
offline attack so in the situation where
you have your wallet file on your
computer it's encrypted with your
password somebody steals your computer
what they're gonna be able to do is
they're gonna be able to look at that
encrypted file try billions of passwords
per second there they've even developed
specialized hardware for password
cracking purposes and so your password
will have to be strong enough that it
must resist at least billions possibly
even trillions of guesses this is very
different from a scenario where you're
using a password to log in to a website
where after three or ten or whatever
number of guesses the attacker is going
to get logged out of the website so
that's called an online attack and most
of us can pick passwords that can resist
an online attack very few of us can pick
passwords that can resist an offline
attack and still remember them
conveniently so in the security
community and the usable security
community getting people to pick
passwords that do resist offline attacks
is considered a very hard problem and so
it's a I would say this is of somewhat
limited use I should point out in one
caveat though there's a cool feature in
iOS that you may or may not know about
and I think Android will also eventually
get it and here's that cool feature if
you enable a pin for iOS and I think
there's also an additional setting
that's in fact turned on by default your
whole disk is encrypted with that pin or
what that password but with an
additional property the additional
property is that trying different
passwords to decrypt your device can
only be done using what is called a
secure coprocessor that resides on your
iPhone so even if somebody gets a hand
gets ahold of your iPhone they can't
simply copy all the disk contents to
another device and try passwords at
billions of times per second that is
simply not possible unless they can
overcome the tamper resistance of that
hardware and tamper resistant hardware
is intended to destroy itself before it
will give
but secrets so this is a very cool
technique that exists in iOS as well as
in the iPhone hardware that allows you
to force attackers to try passwords in
an online fashion as opposed to an
offline fashion and also the iPhone is
set to lock itself up after a certain
number of failed guesses so that method
if you have a device that supports that
if you have a device that forces the
attacker to manually try guess us one by
one then encryption where the password
becomes a really good security technique
and it's also a really usable technique
because you can just get away with a
short pin you don't have to have a super
complicated password yeah so that's the
key difference there's a technique
that's related to this instead of having
a normal wallet file and encrypting it
with a password some people came up with
this cool idea let's say that your
password itself somehow acts as your
Bitcoin private key and that seems a bit
crazy but it's in fact doable with
relatively simple algorithms visually
this is how it work so you have a
password I know that all if you picked
like to pick this password that's from
xkcd so you have an algorithm a
deterministic algorithm that takes any
given password and generates a private
key from it you also have an algorithm
that sort of stretches one private key
into a collection of as many different
private keys as you want and you also
have a third algorithm that can take a
private key and derive the corresponding
public key from it right and that this
notion is called a brain wallet the idea
being that everything you need in order
to spend your bitcoins is stored in your
brain and these all of these three
derivation algorithms are both
deterministic and standardized and
implemented in different pieces of
software and so this is a pretty cool
idea and in fact this is especially good
fodder for sci-fi stories the idea being
that the key to control millions of
dollars worth of bitcoins or how much
ever you want is just in your brain and
so you can travel anywhere you don't
need to take any device with you
you can later acquire a device and
install software that comes built in
with these standardized public
algorithms all algorithms and
crypto Republic and that will help you
regenerate your Bitcoin wallet and take
control the ball of your bitcoins pretty
cool idea yeah question would they be
able to spend each other's wedding very
easy so let's let's think about that so
this is exactly the Achilles heel of the
whole system right it's not only the
case that if two people accidentally
pick the same password they'll be able
to spend each other's money how does it
get even worse than that right so here's
where it gets really crazy so look look
at these functions this is a
deterministic function every arrow
points to a deterministic function and
so if you have an attacker who's trying
to guess passwords they always have the
ability to look at your public key that
you've published try passwords one by
one and brute force said using these
publicly known functions to see if they
hit the same public key so this is not
just offline guessing instead of online
guessing this is even a step further
with the same algorithm the attacker can
try to brute-force everybody's brain
while it's all at once they didn't even
need to know who they're attacking they
can steal the money curse you know
belong to some anonymous person from the
blockchain directly alright and here's
where it gets really cool so think about
this for a second
so you've got these public addresses and
what this means is that corresponding to
any of these if you generate any of
these public addresses from a guessable
password it means that there are
potentially attackers out there who can
scan the blockchain realize you know
what password it came from recreated the
private key and steal your bitcoins
right so if that is the case and if
people are using this brainwallet
software and if they are generating the
Sun secure passwords you can expect
pretty much with certainty that there
are attackers out there that are
scanning the blockchain at all times and
try to see if this is happening so we
did an experiment was I wasn't too
directly involved but Joe Bono at
Princeton and some other collaborators
at Michigan one of my master's students
was involved to try to see if you can
put small amounts of money into these
addresses generated from insecure
passwords and to see what happens we
found that they were getting stolen
within three to five seconds
if the password was sufficiently weak
the attackers actually weren't trying
trillions of possible guesses but if the
password was weak enough than they were
stealing it so this is you know it's a
really neat idea especially for sci-fi
but it's in in the real world I don't
think it's that secure a technique and I
wouldn't recommend that anybody use it
so there's another similar one so let me
actually grab this I have an example of
this here in my actual wallets what I
have is what is called a paper wallet so
this is an example of a paper wallet
with your public key that's encoded as a
two-dimensional QR code and this this
particular one was given out to all
participants in a Bitcoin workshop and
so that's fine
so you're thinking you know it's just a
way to encode your public key on a piece
of paper and you can keep it in your
wallet hopefully you'll remember where
it is but the cool thing is that if you
open up this sort of kind of tamper
resistant part then your private key
pops out so the idea is that if you sort
of believe in the in the tamper
resistance of this so you can and if you
trust the person who created this paper
wallet right the company or whoever who
created this paper wallet you can just
order one on the internet and you can
keep it around and you can go around you
I don't know maybe asking people for
donations and when you want to retrieve
your money you can pop open the private
key and hopefully you never use your
paper wallet again so that's the paper
wallet idea I think it's cute but really
in a practical sense it's not really all
that useful
it's a neat gimmick but it's not gonna
really buy you that much definitely
don't send any money to this address or
try sending money to this address and
see if it does get stolen within three
to five seconds that's also another
experiment you can do we had in the
Bitcoin lecture series that we did at
Felton did a lecture where he covered
many of these ideas that we're talking
about and he flashed something and said
hey here's a Bitcoin public key feel
free to donate some bitcoins to us and
we actually got some Bitcoin donations
out of that without anything with it but
it's pretty cool to see that we didn't
flash the private key though just the
the key okay so let's look at another
idea which has already been suggested
and discussed which is a hosted wallet
and the idea here is just it you just
outsource the storage if your bitcoins
to some company and I think this example
is from coinbase
it shows you a list of account or
wallets that you have and the balances
that each of them contains the list of
all the transactions you've made yada
yada yada everything that you'd expect
exactly like PayPal right so again the
question becomes are you really
benefitting from the privacy and other
features of Bitcoin if you're using a
hosted wallet and again are you and
really want to trust the security to
these companies given that this is not
such a mature and regulated space as of
yet unlike unlike traditional banking
and a lot of these tend to close down
but it's something interesting to
consider okay now let's get to some
pretty neat ideas that involve some
somewhat novel security techniques that
many of you may not have seen so one big
problem with everything that we've
talked about so far is that very often
there is a single point of failure even
if you have a hot wall that cold wall
that separation your hot wallet itself
even if it has only a little money is a
single point of failure so how can you
avoid that how can you do better than
that
roughly speaking there are two different
ways to avoid a single point of failure
one is you have your Bitcoin private key
and you somehow split that key between
multiple devices and the other approach
is you can use a feature of Bitcoin
itself called multi signatures that
allows you to designate to tell the
Bitcoin network that this address is not
a regular address it's not protected by
a single private key it's protected by a
sort of a quorum of private keys and
here the different public key is
corresponding to them and only accept
transactions originating from this
address if at least a certain minimum
number of those private keys come
together and all sign that and sign that
transaction
wait so roughly this is what I'm talking
about
this is called Bitcoin multi signature
so you can associate n different keys
with that address and this is two out of
three so you've associated three
different public keys with that address
and you've specified a threshold in
k-stew of keys that need to sign in
order to be able to spend a transaction
from that address and the Bitcoin
network will ensure this if there's
malware on one of your devices and
somebody's tries to spend a transaction
from that address with only one of those
signatures the network will simply
reject it and so the one of the useful
special cases of this is just the two
out of two case and in a two out of two
multi signature what you're doing is
you're splitting your key or or you
designate two different keys one of
which is on your computer and one of
which is on your phone and so you would
initiate a transaction on your computer
and you'd have to confirm it on your
phone and if there's malware on any one
of these devices you're still okay so
people have gotten farther with this
there's a hybrid model where you can
outsource part of your security to
another company and keep control of it
yourself in an important way at the same
time a little bit of having your cake
and eating it too and what am I talking
about here so again you can utilize
multi signatures what what do you do is
you protect your addresses whether the
two out of three multi signature and of
those three keys
you keep two for yourself you keep one
of them in hot storage and you keep one
of them in cold storage and the third
one you outsource to this company so
let's think about this for a minute I'll
ask you two questions the first is what
what two keys will assign your
transactions in your normal everyday
course of spending and the second
question I'll ask you is is there a way
for you to recover if the service in
fact turns out to be malicious think
about it for a minute and then we'll
look at the answers
okay so here's the idea in the normal
everyday course of spending your
transactions would typically be
authorized by these two keys the key in
your hot storage and the key that you've
outsourced to the service provider the
key near cold storage you don't want to
take it out in the normal course of
things obviously so why is this better
what is this by you compared to just
having one key on your own computer now
one thing that the service provider
might do by default is simply authorize
simply assign every transaction that's
requested in this fashion right so in
that situation it would more or less be
identical to having just one key on your
own computer you're not really using the
capabilities of the multi signature here
why because if your hot Storage is
compromised the attacker would initiate
a transaction the service provider would
go ahead and rubber stamp it and then
the attacker would be able to steal all
your bitcoins from hot storage however
we can do better than that you can set a
spending limits with the website for
example and this is similar to the
spending limit with the hardware
protection that I was talking about you
could say I usually only authorize the
spending of one Bitcoin per day and
they'd say okay and they would freeze
you know they would stop creating
signatures after that limit is reached
and the only way you'd be able to
overcome this limit let's say would be
to call them on the phone authenticate
who you are and say you want to race
that limit so that puts you at a
different level of security you could
also do other things every time a
transaction request has initiated the
service provider has to call you on the
phone and confirm that transaction but
notice that this is absolutely not the
same as outsourcing your security
altogether to the cloud provider why
because it's two out of three Multi
signature so the service provider
themselves has no ability to steal your
funds and if you ever lose your
confidence in them in fact you can
simply forget about their key you can
use your two keys take your key out of
cold storage and then move your front
somewhere else so this is an interesting
hybrid model now I said there are two
ways to avoid a single point of failure
one is to use this feature of the
Bitcoin protocol to designate multiple
keys and the other is you just have a
single key but you somehow split your
key
this is something that I'm guessing most
of you have not seen and this is a very
neat idea called Shamir secret sharing
it uses some interesting properties of
algebra and let me show you what this is
so here is a cool protocol this was
invented in 1979 and this is still one
of the fundamental techniques in crypto
for how to take a piece of information
and split it into different devices with
some very specific properties what are
the properties that we want let's say we
want to do a two out of three secret
sharing of Mikey so what that means is
that if I bring any two of those three
shares as we call them if I bring
together any two of those shares of the
key I should be able to reconstruct the
whole key but if I only have one chair
then that should give me no information
whatsoever about the key having one
chair should not make it any easier to
guess the key than if I had known
nothing at all and so this should make
it clear that the obvious solution of
just concatenating the key into some
number of pieces and putting them on
different devices is simply not going to
work
why because in that situation knowing
one chair does give you some information
about the key so it's not obvious what
to do but there's a clever mathematical
trick you can apply and let me show you
that so this is going to involve some
algebra which I'm going to show you
visually in a geometric form so here's
how to split a key so you represent to
your key K as the point 0 comma K over
here on the y-axis so your key is gonna
be some 128-bit number let's say you
just treat it as a giant number and you
just put plot that point here on this
graph over here so you know we're doing
this on the computer so it doesn't
matter this is but this is K is gonna be
a giant number 128-bit number okay so
now you want to split the key into a
bunch of different pieces here's the
next step you draw a line with a random
slope through that point why are we
doing that it'll become clear in a
second so you draw a line with a random
slope and then you pick some arbitrary
point on that line and that point the X
comma Y pair of that point is going to
be one of the shares and you can give it
to one device or one person or one
friend whatever you want to think of it
you pick a different arbitrary point on
that line you give
to somebody else so what properties this
is have if these two people come
together they can draw the line they can
intercept that with the y-axis they can
figure out the value of K but if you
have only one person who's malicious
who's trying to infer what the secret
was based on the point that they have
then they have literally no information
about what K is because we picked a
random slope it could be any line
through that point so that line could
intersect the y-axis at any point
whatsoever right so a single person has
learned nothing and you can keep doing
this you can give out as many shares as
you like any two of those people can
come together and learn that point but
any individual among them will not be
able to do so it's a pretty cool
property so here I've showed you two out
of n secret sharing you can go further
and you can do em out of n secret
sharing for any M and n so this is we
believe that this has some important
advantages over designating with the
Bitcoin protocol then you want to use
different keys to protect your wallet
and in fact I'm giving a talk about we
did a lot of crypto to actually make
this work with the Bitcoin protocol this
simple thing has been known since 1979
but it's not it's not all that you need
I'll show you in the next line what is
the additional thing that you need
that's some research that we did and I'm
going to be giving a talk about it the
security seminar today at 4:15 if your
interest that's gonna be a complete
crypto talk I'm gonna show the math
behind how a lot of this stuff works
just letting you know if you're
interested so yeah this idea is pretty
simple given any two points you can
interpolate and find K so why is this
not enough why do you need additional
crypto to make this work well here's the
problem I'm showing you how to split the
key but I haven't shown you how to spend
a transaction because when you do want
to create a transaction what are you
going to do are you going to reconstruct
the key in a single place and let's say
you've split it between your computer
and your phone or are you gonna
reconstruct the entire key on one of
those two devices well that's not going
to work because the device that you
choose to reconstruct it on could be
infected with malware and at that point
you've given away your key and so you
haven't really gained anything in terms
of security so this is where the crypto
magic comes in that I was talking about
what we have is something called a
threshold signature protocol and if you
I've heard of that it's pretty cool so
here's what I'm claiming there's a
secret key it's not stored on any
individual one of the devices but shares
of this key are stored on let's say
three different devices and what you can
have is a protocol where these three
different devices come together and
there's a series of communication
between them and at the end of the day
they've managed to construct a signature
that's signed by that private key that's
not in fact stored on any single one of
those devices and they've managed to do
it without reconstructing the key on any
individual device at any one time so it
seems a bit crazy it seems a bit magical
but there's a lot of crypto behind it
and let me just quickly show you what
the user interface behind that would
look like this is something we've
implemented so you would initiate a
transaction on your computer it would
confirm that you want to send something
and it's gonna show you the address that
you want to send it to and the amount of
the transaction and so on and so once
you click send or confirm or whatever a
notification will pop up on your phone
which will include the same parameters
that you saw on the previous screen and
your job would be to make sure that both
of these devices are showing you the
same information because if those two
pieces of information didn't match it
could mean that one of your computers or
one of your devices is compromised and
you could be sending money to the
attacker
instead of whoever you want it wanted to
send it to but you know we and the
others who are working on these problems
we're doing it with no real background
or training and usability and design and
so on I can already think of many
different problems with this many
reasons why this is a suboptimal flow
for users here's one simple example look
at that gibberish address over there
right so if you had the task of
comparing these two addresses between
these two different devices most likely
what you would do is you'd look for the
first several characters and see if they
matched or not so cryptographically
you're guaranteed that no attacker will
be able to generate a malicious address
that matches your address in its
entirety but there's nothing preventing
them from trying a lot of different
addresses until they can generate an
address that matches yours in the first
four or six characters so that's a
serious security voluntarily so a good
design question
as how do you help users compare these
complex sequences of crypto numbers and
digits in a way that doesn't pose a
significant cognitive tax and in a way
that helps them be secure anyway this is
the that interface that it has some
advanced properties that I'll skip over
right now but the bigger point that I
want to make is that in this whole space
design expertise is really desperately
needed there's some preliminary work
there that's the first author's name
over there this is a screenshot from a
paper where they compared many not all
but many of the techniques that we've
talked about today and they examined
them on different directions they came
up with a bunch of properties that are
useful for security and usability is it
resistant to malware and over here you
know how usable it is to users a variety
of different properties and they just
did an analysis based on the
descriptions of these techniques what
they did not do is an actual usability
study they did not go to users and see
how comprehensible each of these were
how usable they were whether or not
users are good at at keeping their
Bitcoin secure so the big open question
to me that all of this really leads to
is what I like to call human crypto
interaction I want to ask the question
is human crypto interaction even
possible that is can we ever will the
security community you've managed to
make it easy enough for users and to
teach you to users to securely store and
manage their keys and this is not
something really that's ever happened so
far the reason that web encryption is
easy today and all of us do it in an
HTTPS is because it's completely
transparent and the only thing if
anything that you noted need to know to
look for is whether there's a green lock
icon in your browser right and similarly
email security is gradually so when I
teach a biometric security I tell my
students that there are three things
they need to remember about biometrics
number one biometrics are not secret
number two biometrics are not secret
number three biometrics are not secret
okay so this is really the key to
understanding biometric security that I
biometrics are not secret so the reason
that fingerprints can be potentially a
secure way to open a door lock for
example is that because absolutely not
because we assume that nobody can figure
out what your fingerprint is it's very
easy you know that especially with the
camera resolutions these days you can
even imagine taking a picture of
somebody from a distance and
reconstructing their fingerprint and
there are lots of security papers that
try to do exactly things like these
however however the reason that a
biometric door lock is supposed to be
secure is that it's supposed to have
sensors in there that ideally is able to
figure out if it's a real live finger
being presented or if it's a fake
fingerprint that somebody has printed
out on a piece of paper right and if the
biometric door locks exceeds at that
task precisely that task of liveness
detection liveness detection is exactly
the security property that you need for
biometrics not secrecy so it's a
completely different security principle
now depending on secrecy but depend on
lightness detection so that's the reason
why it doesn't translate over so well to
the Bitcoin world because there is no
way that you can ever build a secure
system by assuming that fingerprints are
going to be reasonably kept secret but
yeah that's a good point so so this is
sort of the big question that I kind of
want to end with if you look at other
domains of cryptography for example the
reason that web encryption works is that
we've managed to make it completely
invisible we've managed to make it so
that you don't have to go and manually
install certificates or anything like
that in your browser it's because the
only thing you need to know is to check
for the green lock icon and even then
we've had we have a ten percent
penetration of people learning to check
that accurately right and it's something
like that but it's getting better
um similarly an email encryption Apple
iMessage for example is end-to-end
encrypted what does that mean it's not
just encrypted between your mobile
device and Apple's cloud server it's in
fact encrypted all the way from your
mobile device to the mobile device of
the recipient so Apple even if they
wanted are not in a position to
intercept that encrypted communication
this is the reason of course that
Silicon Valley has been absolutely at
loggerheads with law enforcement in the
last couple of years right the FBI and
lots of other law enforcement agencies
wants backdoors
- and - an encrypted communication
precisely for this reason this is not in
the Gmail security model where the
communication is encrypted from your
computer to Gmail server where
potentially a law enforcement can go
serve Google with the subpoena to get it
your emails this is a different model
and encrypted all the way from your
computer to the recipients computer in
the past we thought that this was going
to be essentially impossible to achieve
in a transparent fashion because people
have to exchange each other's public
keys and so on and so forth and people
came up with all kinds of crazy ideas
key signing parties where a bunch of
people come together and physically
verify each other's keys and produce a
digital signatures of them and so on
I've heard that this is very popular in
Europe but but it looks like that's not
the that's not the route that's winning
users that right that's winning users as
to make it completely invisible people
are not even aware that they're using
encrypted messaging and the reason that
that's possible is that specifically
with messaging there's a little bit of a
technical security detail but if you're
interested in the key difference that
enables this is that unlike email it's
not an asynchronous communication
texting is a synchronous communication
both devices are online at the same time
so you can execute a secure key exchange
protocol through which these two users
have never talked before can exchange
keys with each other it doesn't get us
all the security properties that it want
that we want people often call it tofu
security what that means this trust on
first to use security so the security
property that the system gives you is
that you're still talking to the same
person who you initiated the
communication with say three months ago
so that's still pretty good that's still
a reasonably good security property it
means that if somebody one wants to
surveil your communication they must
have inserted inserted themselves into
that communication the very first time
you talk to your friend so that's so
it's still a pretty good security
property and we have that working now we
have it working transparently so in some
domains we've managed this and the
Bitcoin domain security is clearly a
huge problem people are losing lots of
money
there are interesting crypto ideas
floating around but making them usable
and designing for usability is still an
open challenge how are we going to do it
are we going to make it completely
invisible to users are we going to
educate people to learn to
securely store and manage private keys
understand what they mean and back them
up appropriately etc etc it's still
unclear there's a lot of scope for
researcher so I wanted to end on that
note let me know if you're interested in
chatting more about this alright thank
you you talked about it being very
difficult for humans to compare those
keys book sure would it be any easier if
the keys were shown as something like QR
codes instead because yes that's a great
point I don't I don't necessarily know
if it will be easier but I think we
should find the answer by testing it out
okay thanks guys
you